hey guys three months ago I brought your
video mill Sandra's fate in season 7 in
which beside a new encounters of which
in the first one she might get killed
while on the second encounter Melisandre
will in my opinion determine fate of the
Brotherhood without banners I also
introduced you with a theory in which
Melisandre will be at Winterfell almost
the whole season hiding behind her true
form in order to stay by Jon's side so
she could be able to help him once the
Great War comes while 10 days ago this
same theory might have been confirmed by
an actress that plays Melisandre in case
you didn't watch a video in which I
brought you this theory or in case you
don't remember let me remind you with a
few sentences according to this theory
of mine no Sanjay who was last time seen
riding south will either return at
Winterfell at her few encounters that
she will have while riding south or will
actually stay in the north the whole
time and all her encounters will be in
interval the main point of this theory
is that Melisandre will take off her
necklace along with her beauty and youth
with it and will once again reveal her
true form which is a frail old woman who
is approximately 400 years old
Melisandre in her true form will return
to Winterfell
since no one has ever seen her true form
no one actually knows how she really
looks like and will stay by John's side
who she believes is the prince that was
promised so she could help him once the
Great War comes three months ago I
introduced you with this interesting
theory but at the end of the video I
said that this same theory is supported
with absolutely nothing leaving it to
you to decide whether or not will it
come true many of you like this theory
mostly because of Melisandre is last
seen in which she was exiled from North
by Jon Snow for her crime but before Jon
made his decision before Melisandre was
exiled from the north she said you know
the great war still to come you know the
army of the Dead will be upon us soon
and you know I can help you win that war
well there was also a few of you who
said that it's out of the realm of
possibilities however the same theory
seems to be recently confirmed by chris
van hollen
and anxious the place Melisandre on Game
of Thrones the actors posted a close-up
shot of Melisandre shoot forum with the
caption by special makeup team I've ever
worked with
not only that we disposed Chris Van
Hollen has confirmed her uncertain
appearance but has also seemingly
confirmed material in which she will
stay at Winterfell means her true form
and
image roll as she has been playing ever
since the second season Melisandre will
in my opinion play a much bigger role in
the last eight season once the Great War
actually comes but will doubtlessly
continue to be a major character and
will play a huge role in the upcoming
season as she has been doing so far if
you are interested in more details about
mil Sandra's fate in the upcoming season
feel free to check out my video that I
mentioned in the very beginning of this
video and as always let me know your
opinion about all of this in the comment
section down below I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace
[Music]